Speaker 1: We've been
extensively covering the growing
civil war within the Republican Party. The battle
lines are not super clear, but to some degree,
at least at the very top level. The battle lines
are pro-Trump and anti-Trump Republicans, and
one really interesting figure in that is Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis. And he's interesting
because it's not exactly clear which side he's on.
And what I mean by that is early in the pandemic,
when the failed former President Donald Trump was
still the actively failing President Donald Trump.
Ron DeSantis and Trump were very buddy buddy.
Early in the pandemic, DeSantis refused to close
and or very quickly opened major events, sporting
events, all sorts of different things. Trump
pointed to dissent. This is a guy doing the right
thing. And they were very buddy buddy. Over time,
it started to become clear that there was at least
some appetite from within the Republican Party for
an alternative to Trump. And while the alternative
that they seem to be seeking is not, you know,
Mitt Romney, it's it is Ron DeSantis, to some
degree. Ron DeSantis has increasingly been thought
of as an alternative to Trump. Now it's weird
because DeSantis is almost like Trump to the nth
degree. DeSantis has a lot of the same terrible
ideas of Trump, the same political instincts of
Trump, but he's more competent and he's less
cartoonish, and he's probably more dangerous
if he gets the opportunity to be president of
the United States. But so kind of by default,
there started to. Be this well, will it be Trump
2024 or will it be DeSantis 2024? And this has
really triggered Donald Trump to the point where
we now have multiple reports. We've told you about
where Trump is reportedly furious that,
for example, when DeSantis is asked, Hey,
will you run in 2024? DeSantis doesn't go, Oh,
absolutely not. It's Trump's for the taking.
DeSantis hasn't said that, and there are numerous
reports that Trump and people around him are upset
about that. This brings us to this past weekend
at Mar a Lago and at Mar a Lago. Roger Stone,
who was a guest on this program and was was
ultimately convicted and then pardoned, and
he's a friend of Trump. OK, whatever. Roger Stone
was filmed at Mar a Lago, and he goes up to Trump,
and he says, Ron DeSantis is a piece of s.
And that video was initially kind of cut,
so you don't really see what Trump's reaction
is. Now the fuller video has been released.
I'm going to play it for you now. Of course, if
you're listening, you're not going to know what
Trump does. But the big deal that's being made
is Trump nods when Roger Stone tells them Ron
DeSantis is a piece of ass. Let's take a look
at the video. Let's take a listen to the video.
Unidentified: Yes, Roger. How could I not see?
Speaker 1:
OK, so listen, this is not like the big
smoking gun that Trump has, the player declared
open season on Ron DeSantis or anything like
it. There's also we can't ignore that there's
really strange kind of like godfather vibes
at the start of the first Godfather movie
incredible movie. By the way, when I sometimes
when I mentioned The Godfather, people email
saying I'm glorifying violence because it's
a violent film. No, it's just a great film.
The scene at the wedding, where everybody is
kind of making their pilgrimages and saying,
Hello, thank you, Godfather, I have a
favor. I need this. I need that. Oh,
you're so great. There's a similar vibe
to it that's developed at Mar a Lago,
with people coming and making their pilgrimages
to Trump. But putting that aside, there is no
question that Donald Trump is now hostile
to Ron DeSantis, and it's increasingly clear
that voters are aware that there is an alternative
to Donald Donald Trump. So we've looked at these
numbers before, and they continue to improve
slightly. And Ron DeSantis is favor. If you go
to predict it, dawg, where you can bet on who will
be. You can bet on almost anything. They'll take
your action. But one of the things is you can
bet on who will be the 2024 Republican nominee.
Last time we looked at this, it was 39 29.
Thirty nine percent believed it would be Trump
and 29 percent believed it would be DeSantis that
was the closest it had been since the start of,
you know, the discussion of 2024. It
is now tightened up a little bit more
where now it is 38 30. This is based on money
betting. These aren't polls, but if you look at
how people are betting. Thirty eight percent
now believe Trump will be the nominee and
30 percent believe it will be Ron DeSantis. There
is no way Trump's not aware of these numbers,
and DeSantis is quickly gaining ground on Donald
Trump. This is the tightest that it's been. Now,
if you look at actual polling, the most recent
polling I found is from a couple of months ago,
actually almost three months ago. And there you
had Trump at 57 percent. This was a Harvard Caps
Harris poll it had three months ago. Trump was
at 57 percent among Republicans. And DeSantis and
Pence each had 12. Now that's three months ago.
The numbers may well have tightened since then,
but there is, let me put it, a different way. It
is not a foregone conclusion that if there is a
contested 24 primary and Trump runs and DeSantis
runs, that Trump runs away with it there sent the
Sanders has growing support. And increasingly,
people believe he has a real shot. And that's the
first step in having a shot. People believing you
have a shot, it becomes a sort of self-fulfilling
prophecy. So expect that it will get delightfully
ugly. If both Trump and DeSantis keep pointing
towards, I may indeed run. Let me know your
thoughts. We'll have the clip of Roger Stone
and Trump at Mar a Lago on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.